[Música]
o bom essa coisa tava anterior nem vai
precisar do café bar de um azar na hora
bom antes mais votado atrás dizendo que
agradecer o convite da organização como
considerar um expert em que a fé é pra
mim falar um pouco aqui o café da manhã
especial no final da tarde quando
estamos a precisar um pouco mais energia
ou quando temos um trabalho para
entregar para conseguir explicar melhor
o sabor desse café vou fazer aqui uma
introdução pouco teórica como funciona o
nosso nosso corpo e em especial a nossa
mente quem não conhece nosso corpo era
exigido curso de um circo chamado ciclo
circadiano que é um pouco mais que no
ciclo biológico do final que é a nossa
primeira vai acordar o nosso verão
branco tentar fazer o nosso autor na no
final do dia antes da meia noite é o
nosso em vários e este seria o momento
em termos maior concentração que de
manhã é a melhor altura para fazer
exercício físico é por volta das 5 horas
e também quando nós temos deitar e
acordar a esses dois acho que as pessoas
acabam por esquecer uma questão muito
importante em maior detalhe existe um
outro ciclo que se chama circo se
ficaria ou trair a aqui é mais adaptado
a cada pessoa e que nos permite ver
quais são os nossos filhos a performance
oficialmente conseguir um estado muito
tempo concentrados extradição 95 o trade
anualmente tem um tempo máximo de uma
hora uma hora e manhã então 50 mãe o
ciclo do sono há momentos em que nós
temos que ver o momento em que vamos
porque é denunciar acaba muitas vezes
queremos até tardou a por volta das três
da tarde e cruzar aquela se não é
servida na cico o trabalho é bom o
último ciclo e para acabar com a mataria
teórica o sion sono aí eu penso que é um
dos mais importantes do meio por quatro
micro microciclos a medição há cerca de
oito horas as crianças são dez dias
tempo acaba
por ser menor nota no site vai desde
então já sentei com sono entramos em
sono profundo voltamos a ter o sonho
chamado hair rápido e movimento é
movimento rápido dos olhos e quando
nosso cérebro tem uma atividade muito
próxima quando estamos acordados e nessa
altura por exemplo
sonhamos há voltamos a entrar num sono
profundo momento ideal para acordar diz
agora quando temos um sono porque nossa
cerebral é muito próxima da nossa
actividade no dia a dia isso vai
permitir um acordar só vou encontrar
quando acordamos num sono profundo e
acordamos nem temos oito agora se parece
com um caminhão por cima nós e é paga
mais acordar mas o sisvan voltar a
dormir pois bem eu só na mesma chave
para uma saúde mental porque a é o
momento em que nós possamos nos
informação que recolhemos durante o dia
- poucas horas esse processamento e
armazenamento vai ser feito forma
eficiente é quando a carga das baterias
é como nossa novas temos a final do dia
antes de dormir eu estava largado para
conseguir vencer a bateria até o final
do dia seguinte
assim tivemos não está chateado é
preciso uma hora vai ter que emprestar
eu voltar a cantar
passa-se o mesmo conosco senão teremos
vai no final de vamos precisar então num
café é uma bebida energética e vamos ter
uma outra nota está no álbum se começa a
cortar cursos quando tem pouca bateria
mesmo acontece conosco chegamos à final
e com pouca bateria também vamos estar
afetados muito importante só não é muito
fácil há muitas pessoas dormem
considerado tempo necessário à para
comprar mas tem uns ou de má qualidade e
isso acabava a acordar estava cansada se
estava cansada sempre estiveram porque
então vim mesmo muitas vezes saímos
sobre cansaço e não tem noção de são
limitadas
o sono é frágil ao ponto de uma
temperatura muito alta é no quarto por
exemplo afetar a qualidade do sono
a luminosidade eu por exemplo não
costumo dormir com opcional artesanato
causa do calor mas essa luminosidade
acaba por afetar o meu sonho eu consigo
ter a noção de si mesmo barulho a estar
em locais com muito ruído acabam por
wilson afetada e não tem noção de si
mesmo pessoas com problemas
respiratórios no cinema
dormem oito horas e acabam portar sempre
cansados
estudos recentes apontam os textos
diferentes aponta que um em cada três
adultos não dorme o suficiente ou seja
não estão a carregar o sustento das
baterias está a afetar a vida é a vida
delas foi responsável em primeiro lugar
para avançar no nosso sistema defensivo
isso vai parecer um conjunto de doenças
temos uma semana muito exausta acredita
que é muito mais fácil ficamos triste
passar e em casos mais graves o aumento
de pressões jornal tão comuns situações
que acabam por uns gastos continuam nos
lavar e se agora sobre o só para
terminar a opção de só quero deixar uma
dica para quem tem problemas de insônia
a criação de rotinas é a melhor forma de
nos pronunciarmos rapidamente
muita gente já se consigo dormir depois
de uma séria só consigo dormir pode ser
normal que acontece é que nós queremos é
certeira todos os dias faz aquilo e uma
cor pode saber que é hora de dormir
então quando foi para a cama
vai ser muito bom estar todo mundo se á
por isso conseguir entender uma antena
de dormir não conseguirá melhorar o
nosso bom mas não é só sobre sónia há
muitas vezes pensamos mas nunca foi
tamanho que a nosso ver cada vez mais
trabalho competitivos cada vez mais
trabalho para fazer cada vez menos tempo
para a família e para os amigos e nós
começamos esse tempo à noite
trabalhamos desde as novas seis novas
sedes
o gestor área que vamos pôr tempos de
mix durante a noite estavam uma vez mais
apostar no tempo de sono mas também
viver sua vida disse tracey tem como
cores pra botar aquela hora me que o
local pois na aplicação no mercado não
vou treinar isso acaba por não tirar o
tempo todo a decorrer da vida
portanto a eu diria que o importante é
nós percebemos como é que o nosso corpo
funciona para saber qual o melhor
momento de fazer vou fazer uma das
tarefas e isso talvez seja o nosso dia a
dia
então a gente sabe os espanhóis nós
temos armas mas gostam tirar uma se esta
por volta das três e isso é pôr o nosso
corpo anos e cultura bianual da próxima
semana ou em si
e aí é uma boa estratégia mas por
exemplo a de manhã quando temos maior
concentração em norma
e há um estudo que foi feito há cerca de
três anos sobre a decisão do juiz foi
publicado no new york times
a número do título tendência apontar
analisaram cerca de mil decisões tomadas
por juízes sobretudo pena suspensa e ela
e assustou mostrou que há mais de 80%
dos pedidos de pena suspensa não
autorizados quando a decisão é tomada de
manhã só os concretistas iguais culpa de
grãos a 30 tarde não tenham o clube pena
suspensa a 7 mas o começo que este
coisas podem afetar as decisões e os
teus vida de cada pessoa
sobre ter ouvido a síndrome atividade
física e nutrição são mais sábios do dia
a dia
no entanto existem alguns há alguns
fatores ou pequenas medidas podemos
tomar um dia estou cá eu tenho um bom
hábito tem uma movimentação consegui
controlar o sono mas hoje teve um dia
que não consegui mesmo deitado até um
pouco até o benefício o que eu posso
fazer
bom o café o café é nojento olha para um
café com o move é uma dúvida e toma por
gosto ou entrasse não dava outra tal
deformação do café é a franja curta café
em londrina nas substituições têm café
mas vamos dizer que o café é para ajudar
a reduzir o nosso nosso cansaço insônia
para quem não tomam café diariamente
então nunca ferimento café acaba o nosso
organismo datas alcancei o café não vai
ter esse efeito em que trabalham em
turnos noturnos quem de fato observa um
café e viola que não tomam café
diariamente para sentir o efeito das
café quando realmente precisar
outra técnica é chamada certa ou neve
o trabalho para vermelha no japão quem
dorme o trabalho é o tipo realmente está
a desfrutar e aqui começamos a ver
muitas empresas também é criar em há
espaço para para os cobradores parar em
seus 20 e 30 minutos
filha de 30 minutos e é um entre algumas
vezes tivemos a meio da tarde a e pode
ajudar muito a conseguir uma receita
antiga que é mané primazé powers
superpower neto
basicamente tomar um café
a quem toma raramente manter o iphan e
hidratar e tirarmos um sonho de 30
minutos
é bom porque vou tomar um câncer para
dentro mesmo com essa fase feito passar
30 minutos em média no organismo da
pessoa seja vou tomar um café e quando
acordaram manter o efeito da piraí mas o
efeito do café acredita que isso possa
ajudar é quase constrangido mesma noite
todo vai ajudar muito quando precisar
continuar ainda com sono e eu queria
fazer aqui uma uma pequena triagem
convosco tem aqui um cenário que foi
criado com a escola ensina estampar a
ideia samsonov perguntas e cada uma
delas a que atribuem pontes a que acaba
com o metal se alguém quiser o que
resultava móvel para acompanhar para
perceber se estão a ter um sono cuidado
né
então a primeira pergunta todos
preparados costumam ter dificuldades há
quanto tempo eu costumava precisar para
não ser usada 15 minutos quatro pontos
16 e 33 pontos 31 45 29 mais memória 0
pontos
a segunda pergunta só costumam acordar
durante a noite quanto tempo precisa
para voltar 100 e 15 4 pontos 16 de 33
pontos 31 a 45 2 pontos mais demora 0
pontos terceira pergunta costumam
acordar antes do tempo que planeiam
acordar o quanto antes recorda 10 a 15
minutos quatro pontos 16 e 33 pontos 31
45 2 e mais demora 10 pontos
estou manterá em média problemas por
noite ao anunciar 064 pontos
duas noites três pontos 32 pontos 41 57
sabonetes pergunta numa 5 como
classificam a qualidade do sono muito
boa quatro pontos boa 392 fraca um muito
fraca é o nosso estado moral a
simbologia própria relação tem com
outras pessoas
a não de todo 41 pouco 3 às vezes dois
muito um extremamente 0 e é nossa
produtividade concentração mesmo não de
todo o quadro um pouco 3 às vezes hoje
muitas vezes um a um os treinamentos 10
pontos
estamos quase a última em geral afeta
tem 101 seguir a afetada no dia a dia
por questões onu ou de cansaço não todo
quatro pontos um pouco trecho às vezes
dois muito um setor extremamente 0
por fim às desculpas opções estão
erradas eu eu vou gritar quanto tempo
tem tido problemas de sono 06 04 pontos
um a dois meses 3.362 mais 60 pontos e
agora vamos então ver saque pessoas com
problemas de sono tranqüila
então a gente tem as contas feitas
alguém está entre 10 e 19 uma pessoa ao
médico
a série está na nova série que
aconselhou a consultar um especialista
porque é é considerado grave mas é
verdade
10 18 álbum rock é questão de salientar
mas já tem os seus problemas que falamos
e vão conseguir acredita em melhorar
nossa vida
1927 era o que eu esperava maior parte
das pessoas
acho que estão entrando num bom hábito
há sempre espaço para melhorar
e por fim 2836 é pai
braga tem que olhar a vida está ter uma
boa quantidade sony importante com isso
é que nós conseguimos modelo que nós
fazemos ao no caso se nós conseguirmos
faremos o que estamos a fazer vai nos
permitir tomar decisões a usar uma fita
2001 e blogs usar o curso tecnologias
para usar nossa cola do sono
a nossa actividade mas não tinha fins de
alimentação vai vai nos permitir
perceber o que eu estou errado
estou errado porque minha colaboração na
fraca não ter número suficiente a minha
meditação itamar e essas medidas no e as
situações no dia vão permitir melhorar a
nossa vida porque não conseguimos ver
finalmente vamos conseguir reverter a
situação
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]